So now it's time to cover the building blocks to use when doing datestore
modelling. They are kind, entity, and
property. Let's start with kind shall we? A kind
is a name that defines a particular
structure. For our conference central application, two different
kinds are, for example, profile and conference.
A kind is similar to the concept of
classes in object oriented programming. Given a kind
you can create many entities of that kind, so
in this picture we can do three entities, one
for the profile kind and two for the conference
kind. And as you can see entities are very
similar to the concept of objects in object oriented
programming, and each entity holds a set of properties
which are highlighted by the red sections in this
picture, and by now you can see that
properties are very similar to the concept of fields,
members, or attributes in object oriented programming. In
fact, you can also find similarities with the relational
of database modeling. Let's look at the table
that summarizes these things. So the kind in app
engine datastore can be thought of as a class
in object oriented programming and as a table in
relational database model, and an entity in app engine
datastore can be thought of as an object in
object oriented programming or as a row in relational
database modeling. And finally, a property in Datastore can
be thought of as a field or attribute in
object oriented programming, and that's a colomn, in relational
database modeling. But, this is on a very high
level. Since there are many things that differ in Datastore
compared to the other technologies, you shouldn't consider these
as direct technology. It could help you out in the
beginning, but as we dig deeper into how data store
works, you will start to see more and more differences